Same code. Different config per environment. Config maps make that work. Picture this database
host equals local host hardcoded in your app. Works in dev breaks in production. The fix
seems obvious, bake config into the image. But then every environment change means a
build. Config map breaks that cycle. It stores configuration outside your container image
as key value pairs. Once you have a config map, pods consume it three ways. First, environment
variables inject values directly into the container. Second, command line arguments pass
config values as flags at startup. Third, files mounted in a volume. Drop a whole settings
file at a path like slash etc slash config slash settings dot yaml. Four rules before you use
them. Not for secrets, there is no encryption, never store passwords here. Size cap one megabyte,
bigger than that use a volume or external storage. Namespace scoped. The config map must
live in the same namespace as the pod. Since version one, 19, you can mark a config map immutable.
No accidental overwrites. Lighter on the API server. One image. Three environments. Three
config maps. Zero rebuilds. Kubernetes dot config maps.